schönen guten Abend Sebastian Kurz
schönen guten Abend nach Berlin Angela
Merkel die ex-kanzlerin bekommt gerade
Preise für ihre Flüchtlingspolitik
verdient
liegt wahrscheinlich im Auge des
Betrachters es ist ja bekannt dass ich
hier zu Beginn der flüchtlingskrise
schon eine andere Linie vertreten habe
ich glaube es gab dann viele
Diskussionen Gespräche auf europäischer
Ebene und mehr und mehr den Versuch in
Europa dass man Zuwanderung doch steuert
das nicht die Schlepper entscheiden wer
nach Europa durchkommen
darf und ich halt nach wie vor den
Zugang einer kontrollierten Zuwanderung
und der staatlichen Entscheidung wer
zuwandert und wer nicht für den
richtigen also sie hatten ja jetzt
aktuell dafür keinen Orden verliehen und
haben auch nicht gratuliert
also ich bin sowieso nicht in der
Situation Orden zu verleihen ich bin
auch nicht da um um hier sozusagen einen
Widerspruch zu suchen sondern ich glaube
schlicht an der greifend meine Meinung
hat sich eben nicht verändert ich glaube
schlicht und ergreifend daran dass wir
als Europäische Union sehr genau selber
entscheiden müssen wer nach Europa
zuwandert und wer nicht wenn man sich im
internationalen Vergleich umsieht dann
gibt es viele Staaten die offen sind für
Migration aber für qualifizierte
Migration wenn ich nach Kanada schaue
oder nach Australien zum Beispiel
sind aber viele Teile der Welt zurecht
meiner Meinung nach sehr konsequent wenn
es darum geht
illegale Migration zu verhindern und was
wir im Moment gerade erleben ist dass er
nicht nur zurecht viele Menschen aus der
Ukraine fliehen und die Ukraine
verlassen müssen also echte
Kriegsflüchtlinge sind sondern wir
erleben dass die Zahl
die auch illegal aus anderen Teilen der
Welt sich auf den Weg nach Europa macht
dass diese Zahl wieder steigt und das
ist etwas was ich persönlich für
problematische empfinde und ich glaube
wenn man hier nicht gegensteuert wenn es
nicht schnell Druck von Seiten der
Europäischen Union gibt diese illegalen
Migrationsströme wieder zu stoppen dann
werden die Zahlen weiter massiv
ansteigen und wir werden in manchen
Ländern nahe an das kommen was wir im
Jahr 2015 oder 2016 erlebt haben die
Bilder sind Österreich ich zeige Ihnen
die die Bundespolizei die deutsche
Bundespolizei von paar Tagen gemacht hat
das sind wirklich frische Bilder von der
Grenze von Grenzkontrollen dort an der
deutschen Grenze also wieder Flüchtlinge
in Autos gefert in lastergefährcht hier
sie kennen solche schrecklichen Bilder
Dramen hat das ausgelöste in den
vergangenen Jahren was geht ihnen da
durch den Kopf bei diesen Bildern
ja ich finde es dramatisch dass das noch
immer von manchen nicht als Problem
gesehen wird denn es ist ja nicht nur so
dass Staaten in Europa egal ob das
Österreich Deutschland oder Schweden
oder andere sind durch massive
illegale Migrationsströme überfordert
sind sondern es ist ja gleichzeitig so
dass solche Migrationsströme auch dazu
führen dass unglaublich viele Menschen
am Weg nach Europa ihr Leben verlieren
weil sie eben von Schleppern und der
unmenschlichen Bedingungen transportiert
werden weil sie bei der Überfahrt im
Mittelmeer ihr Leben verlieren also es
ist ein grausames Geschäft das hier
stattfindet von dem einzig und allein
die Schlepper profitieren und wenn es
keinen Fokus auf das Thema gibt wenn sie
keinen entsprechenden Druck gibt dann
wird dieses Problem wieder immer größer
werden und wir werden wieder vor einer
ähnlichen Herausforderung stehen wie wir
schon mal hatten also wir sind nicht
gerüstet für diesen wie manche Experten
sagen historischen
wenn ich mir die Zahlen anschaue und die
österreichischen zum Beispiel kenne ich
relativ genau dann sind knapp 100.000
Menschen aus der Ukraine nach Österreich
gekommen die
vor Krieg und und und und Leid geflohen
sind das sind Menschen die fliehen
mussten das sind vor allem Frauen das
sind vor allem Kinder das sind in den
seltensten Fällen Männer wenn man sich
die Migrationsbewegungen aus anderen
Teilen der Welt anschaut dann ist das
eine ganz andere Zusammensetzung und die
Zahlen aus anderen Teilen der Welt sind
bei uns aber ähnlich so hoch wie aus dem
Kriegsgebiet Ukraine das halte ich für
höchst problematisch ich merke das auch
in Deutschland die aufgriffszahlen
wieder steigen auch die Zahlen steigen
bei einer
Millionen Flüchtlinge und Flüchtlinge
die über die Balkanroute gekommen sind
vor allen Dingen aus Syrien jetzt alle
zusammen zählt weit über einer Million
mittlerweile die Zahlen übersteigen die
Zahlen von 2016 aller Voraussicht nach
am Jahresende also haben den Eindruck
dass wir gut gerüstet sind
ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass Europa
im Moment sehr gut gerüstet ist ich
glaube aber dass es
relativ einfach wäre da wieder einen
richtigen Weg einzuschlagen es ist aus
2015 und den Folgejahren eigentlich
bekannt was gemacht werden muss nämlich
nicht wegzusehen nicht das Problem klein
zu reden nicht
die Politik der offenen Grenzen zu
verfolgen sondern an den Außengrenzen
Menschen zu stoppen Schlepper konsequent
zu verfolgen und auch zu bestrafen und
im Idealfall wenn Menschen sich auf den
Weg machen Sie möglichst schnell in ihre
Herkunftsländer zurückzustellen und
nicht zuzulassen dass sie bis nach
mittlereuropa weiterziehen das ist ja
schneller manchmal
das sind ihre Worte und ihre Warnungen
von vor drei vier fünf Jahren und
mittlerweile investieren wir viel viel
mehr Geld in frontext ich habe gerade
noch mal nachgeschaut fast 800 Millionen
Euro im Jahr für Frontex und trotzdem
sieht so aus trotzdem zeigen die Zahlen
wieder massiv
ja schon aber es geht oft nicht nur
darum wie viel Geld investiert wird
sondern wofür sie investiert wird und
was das Mandat ist mit dem eine Einheit
wie Frontex ausgestattet ist oder wie
die rechtliche Situation ist und ich
glaube ein Problem dass wir einfach nach
wie vor haben ist das wenn Menschen sich
auf den Weg machen und bis nach
Mitteleuropa durchkommen und hier einen
Asylantrag stellen dann bleiben sie im
Regelfall da wenn er positiv ausgeht
sowieso und wenn er negativ ausgeht dann
in vielen Fällen auch weil Abschiebungen
dann wiederum nicht stattfinden oder
nicht stattfinden können das heißt das
ganze System ist eins das so aufgestellt
ist dass es nicht nur lösbar ist durch
Geld hineinwerfen sondern es geht auch
um die Frage welches Mandat hat Frontex
welche Kompetenzen gibt wie entschlossen
geht man gegen Schlepper vor
arbeitet man mit den Herkunftsländern
und versucht die Menschen auch möglichst
schnell zurückzuführen wenn sie sich
illegal auf den Weg machen wenn jemand
im Mittelmeer gerette wird in welche
Richtung wir da dann gebracht nach
Europa oder zurück zu der Küste wo er
das Land verlassen hat das sind die
entscheidenden Fragen jetzt schlagen
ganz viele Landräte also auf kommunaler
Ebene in Deutschland Alarm und sagen wir
haben schlicht keine Unterkünfte mehr
bei uns würden sie Turnhallen wieder
umrüsten und zu flüchtlingsunterkünften
machen
also da muss ich mich in die deutsche
Innenpolitik nicht ein und ich glaube es
weiß jede Kommune Lokal sicherlich am
besten wie sie mit der Situation
umzugehen hat ich glaube worum es geht
ist nie schlichter und ergreifend nicht
nur für die Unterbringung zu sorgen
sondern neben der Notwendigkeit der
Unterbringung derer die schon da sind
auch darauf zu achten dass man illegale
Migration bekämpft und versucht uns das
Problem nicht immer größer wird ich habe
die Frage gestellt nicht weil es mir um
eine Botschaft an die Landräte ging oder
um das vor Ort zu organisieren sondern
weil ich über das Signal sprechen wollte
dass da für die Bevölkerung in diesen
Orten entsteht die haben jetzt ein
corona-winter noch ein corona-winter
hinter sich da war ganz oft
Sportunterricht in den Schulen nicht
möglich ist ausgefallen über lange Zeit
und jetzt will man im Einzelnen also in
einigen Orten in Süddeutschland bereits
Turnhallen wieder umrüsten also wieder
aus dem Schulbetrieb rausnehmen und
jetzt zu flüchtlingsunterkünften wieder
machen was macht das mit den Menschen
ich glaube es zeigt einfach dass seine
Überforderung des System gibt es zeigt
das zu Recht unsere Systeme nicht darauf
ausgelegt sind unbegrenzt Menschen
aufzunehmen und ich halte es auch nicht
für den richtigen Weg es wird immer so
sehr auf die Unterbringung im ersten
Moment geschaut ich war jahrelang in
Österreich für die Integration zuständig
ich kann Ihnen sagen die Unterbringung
das ist das geringste Problem einen
Menschen eine Zeit lang irgendwo
ordentlich zu versorgen das ist alles
organisierbar was wirklich
herausfordernd ist ist eine hohe Zahl an
Menschen aus ganz anderen Kulturkreisen
die teilweise sehr schlecht ausgebildet
sind in unseren Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren in unsere Kultur zu
integrieren in
unsereren Staat zu integrieren die
Sprache zu lehren und auch ein
friedliches Zusammenleben zu
organisieren das diese Integration von
einer hohen Zahlen an Menschen ist die
wesentlich größere Herausforderung als
die kurzfristige Unterbringung darum
kann man auch meiner Meinung nach
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine Frauen
Kinder die vor Krieg und Verfolgung
fliehen und eigentlich als oberstes Ziel
haben schnell wieder zurückzukehren kann
man nicht vergleichen mit
Migrationsströmen von sehr vielen jungen
Männern aus ganz anderen
Kulturkreisen aus teilweise sehr
schlechten Ausbildungsverhältnissen mit
dem menschlichen nachvollziehbaren Ziel
hier eine bessere Zukunft zu finden ich
sage dazu menschlich zu 100 Prozent
nachvollziehbar aber für unsere Systeme
für unseren Arbeitsmarkt für unseren
Sozialstaat einfach sehr sehr
herausfordernd also gute Flüchtlinge
schlechte Flüchtlinge
geht nicht um gute und schlechte sondern
es ist glaube ich notwendig einfach zu
unterscheiden was was ist menschlich zu
100% nachvollziehbar wenn jemand an
einem anderen Teil der Welt lebt und der
schlechten Bedingungen und die
Möglichkeit hat nach Europa aufzubrechen
in einem Sozialstaat wie Deutschland
oder Österreich wo die Sozialleistungen
ein Vielfaches von dem Einkommen sind
dass er in seinem Herkunftsland jemals
wird verdienen können dann kann ich das
menschlich zu 100% nachvollziehen aber
es ist trotzdem einfach bei uns
etwas das berücksichtigt werden muss
dass unsere Systeme nur dann
funktionieren können unser Sozialstaat
nur dann funktionieren kann wenn es mehr
Leute gibt die einzahlen in das System
als Menschen die etwas herausnehmen und
auch starke Sozialstaaten wie Österreich
Deutschland Schweden und andere können
einfach nicht unbegrenzt Menschen
aufnehmen die relativ schlecht
ausgebildet
in unsere Länder kommen natürlich März
hat in dieser Sendung mit Blick auf die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge von
sozialtourismus gesprochen hat den
Begriff dann zurückgenommen aber es gab
riesen Empörung nachvollziehbar
ich habe die Debatte nicht im Detail
verfolgt und darum möchte ich es
ehrlicherweise auch nicht kommentieren
er hat darüber gesprochen dass es ein
pull-faktor gibt hier im deutschen
Sozialsystem und es ging dann sie kennen
die Debatte aus Österreich ganz genauso
über um hohe Sozialleistungen jetzt
haben wir hier gerade in Deutschland das
Bürgergeld auch noch eingeführt das
heißt ukrainische Flüchtlinge bekommen
dann noch mal mehr Geld und das entsteht
eine Gerechtigkeitsfrage in dem Land das
im Moment sehr stark belastet ist ist
das ungerecht beispielsweise wenn jemand
der Steuern zahlen der Deutschland seit
sehr sehr vielen Jahren arbeitet sich
seine warme Wohnung nicht mehr leisten
kann und dann beispielsweise dem
Flüchtling in der Unterkunft ordentlich
die Heizung hochgedreht wird und dass
der Staat bezahlt
sie kennen jetzt die die deutschen
Regelungen in dem Bereich nicht im
Detail darum Bedingung Verständnis dass
ich da nicht im Detail einsteigen kann
ich glaube ganz grundsätzlich und das
weiß ich noch aus meiner politischen
Zeit in Österreich haben wir natürlich
innerhalb Europas sehr wohl die Frage
gibt es Sozialleistungen ab dem ersten
Tag oder gibt es einen Vorteil für all
jene die einbezahlt haben ich habe in
Österreich immer dafür geworben und das
sehe ich auch nach wie vor so dass wenn
jemand ein Leben lang gearbeitet hat und
in Pension ist dann muss seine Pension
höher sein als das was ein
mindestsicherungempfänger bekommt der
noch nie in seinem Leben gearbeitet hat
oder etwas beigetragen hat also insofern
ich habe würde ich sagen sehr
grundsätzlich eine klare Meinung dazu
dass ein Sozialstaat nur dann
funktioniert wenn man jedem der Leistung
erbringen kann auch Leistung abverlangt
wenn Menschen die arbeitsfähig sind auch
arbeiten gehen und
so Dienstleistungen wirklich für
diejenigen vorbehalten sind die diese
Unterstützung auch wirklich brauchen
sonst funktioniert das Sozialstaat am
Ende des Tages nicht mehr aber wie
gesagt das als österreichischer Blick
über die Grenze ohne jetzt in die
detail-debatte in Deutschland einsteigen
zu wollen wohl wissen dass die deutschen
Regeln hier ohnehin mit den
österreichischen nicht eins zu eins
vergleichbar sind sie sind jetzt viel in
Amerika im Moment familiär und beruflich
natürlich nicht mehr ganz so viele in
Europa und schauen vielleicht mit dem
anderen Blick aus einem anderen Blick
auch auf Europa wenn sie das alles sehen
flüchtlingskrise aber dann vor allen
Dingen Energiekrise der Krieg der so
dicht an uns gerade tobt ist das Europa
ein Sterbender Kontinent
also ich bin sehr viel in Europa und
auch im Nahen Osten im Moment und ich
muss sagen wenn ich die Europäische
Union die USA mit liest oder einige auch
asiatische Länder
vergleiche dann habe ich natürlich das
Gefühl dass jetzt in Europa gerade sehr
viel zusammenkommt ich bleibe
langfristig ein Optimist aber was
definitiv gelingen muss ist in Europa
einen Ausweg aus aus dieser
Gesamtsituation im Moment zu zu finden
was mir meistens so gemacht ist
dass wir es mit Wladimir Putin mit
jemandem zu tun haben der einfach bis
jetzt jede rote Linie überschritten hat
und selbst wenn es gelingt dass die
Ukraine militärischer erfolgreich ist
wenn es gelingt dass die Ukraine sich
verteidigen kann was wir uns ja alle
zurecht wünschen dann glaube ich doch
dass es am Ende des Tages so sein wird
das Wladimir Putin keine Niederlage als
ob oder eine Niederlage niemals als
lohnt sieht und ich habe die große Sorge
dass auch wenn das vielleicht nicht das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario ist aber dass
ihm auch zuzutrauen ist dass am Ende des
Tages Atomwaffen einsetzt und ich glaube
die Kombination aus dieser massiven
Bedrohung gleichzeitig sehr sehr hohen
Energiepreisen einer extrem hohen
Inflation das ist eine eine ganz ganz
schwierige Situation in der Europa im
Moment gerade ist wo ich hoffe dass man
Schritt für Schritt diese Themen wird
lösen können wenn sie Europa mit einem
Menschen vergleichen würde egal welchen
Altersheim würde er wahrscheinlich nicht
in den Kopf kommen dass das gerade Kraft
strotzender 17 oder 18-Jähriger ist ein
Rentner ein Pensionär
naja schauen Sie ich glaube das Problem
dass wir eben im Moment neben dem Krieg
der das Hauptthema zurecht ist haben ist
das einfach die deutsche die
österreichische Industrie sehr stark in
den letzten Jahrzehnten trotz hoher
Lohnkosten
international erfolgreich sein konnte
weil wir große Absatzmärkte hatten wie
China und andere Teile der Welt weil wir
relativ günstige Energiekosten im
internationalen Vergleich auch aufgrund
der russischen Energie hatten und so ist
es gelungen mit viel Fleiß
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein
wenn es jetzt statt Work-Life-Balance in
Europa mehr und mehr live-balance gibt
und immer weniger Fleiß und und Anpacker
Mentalität wie man sie aus der
Vergangenheit kennt der Generationen die
nach dem Krieg
Österreich und Deutschland wieder
aufgebaut haben wenn es höhere
Energiekosten gibt und wir dann noch
mehr und mehr in einer geteilten Welt
leben also dieses die kappeling von
China zum Beispiel vorangetrieben wird
und dadurch auch große wichtige
Absatzmärkte in Zukunft immer ungewisser
werden dann ist das eine Gesamtsituation
die mir Sorge macht weil so eine
Gesamtsituation einfach zu weniger
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit führt zu einer der
Industrialisierung zu Wohlstandsverlust
und Arbeitslosigkeit und ich glaube in
all diesen Bereichen müssen wir
versuchen gegenzusteuern ich hoffe dass
wir in Zukunft auch in einer
globalisierten Welt leben in der Europa
die deutsche die österreichische
Industrie in alle Himmelsrichtungen
exportieren kann ich hoffe dass es
gelingt die Energiepreise wieder auf ein
etwas
wettbewerbsfähigeres Niveau zu
reduzieren auf ein normaleres Niveau zu
bringen nicht nur für jeden Einzelnen
sondern vor allem auch damit die
industriewett arbeitsfähig bleibt und
ja wenn wenn dazu noch dasselbe Anspruch
vorhanden ist und auch dieselbe
anpackungmentalität wie es glaube ich
lange Zeit in Europa der Fall war dann
wird die Zukunft schon eine positive
sein andernfalls gibt es glaube ich
viele Teile der Welt die aufholen oder
uns sogar überholen Anpacker Mentalität
die da sprechen sie über die
Vergangenheit und es interessant sie
klingen wie Wolfgang Schäuble der ganz
ähnlich vergangene Woche hier in dieser
Sendung gesprochen hat und der gesagt
hat wir wir haben so zu angenehm gemacht
in unserem Wohlstand und gar kein
Vorwurf das ist ganz normal wenn man im
Wohlstand lebt aber wir haben es so ein
bisschen verlernt uns anzustrengen und
der hat auch kritisiert die vielen
Menschen die lieber weniger arbeiten
würden
Work-Life-Balance sprechen Sie also an
wir müssen uns also wieder mehr
anstrengen wir haben es verlernt richtig
richtig zu schuften
ich glaube man kann es nicht so
pauschalieren aber es gibt auch in
Europa nach wie vor eine große Vielfalt
und ich kenne auch viele junge Menschen
in Europa die nach wie vor ein Hunger
nach Erfolg haben ich glaube nur was uns
bewusst sein muss nichts ist Gott
gegeben und die Dinge können sich
einfach sehr schnell ändern Europa ist
nach wie vor ein extrem lebenswerter
Kontinent aber wenn ich mich auf der
Welt umschaue dann kann ich nur sagen
ich verspüre in vielen anderen Teilen
der Welt wo ich gerade unterwegs bin
wesentlich mehr Dynamik wesentlich mehr
auch Anstrengung und Wille zum Erfolg
und wenn sie sich Orte wie Singapur oder
andere Staaten anschauen die waren vor
einigen Jahrzehnten noch alles andere
als entwickelt und haben uns jetzt im
Wohlstand mehr als nur eingeholt also es
ist es findet auf unserer Welt eine
ständige
Veränderung statt und ich glaube wir
müssen schlicht und ergreifend aufpassen
dass wir hier nicht zurückfallen aber
Herr kurz dann ist es doch ein riesen
Fehler jetzt zu gehen mit uns mit dem
Problem hier alleine zu lassen dann
müssen sie doch bleiben
ich bin ja gar nicht weg ich habe ja
nach wie vor meinen Wohnsitz in
Österreich ich bin relativ viel
unterwegs aber wir fliegen von Wien aus
also sprich ich bin zumindest eine Woche
im im
Monat nach wie vor in Österreich ich
zahlen meine Steuern da ich habe meine
Unternehmen hier gegründet also ich bin
überzeugter patriotischer Österreicher
und europäischer
nein ich bin einfach ganz gerne
international tätig und unterwegs und
genieße es sehr auch von anderswo andere
Eindrücke mitzubekommen und je mehr man
das versucht und je mehr man andere
Teile dieser Welt sieht desto mehr sieht
man eben ja dass wir in Europa oft das
Gefühl haben wir sind der Mittelpunkt
der Welt und das Problem ist nur alle
anderen sehen das nicht so danke für das
Gespräch Sebastian Kurz
vielen Dank
[Musik]